yes it's the home opener
yes they're about to get those world
series rings
but i think the thing that is most
special about today for a lot of us
is that this wonderful place
is about to get its voice back
so today
happily
i have the great pleasure
to introduce
the first
dodger manager
since my father
to receive the world series championship
ring
mr dave roberts
now it's time to bring out the members
of the 2020 world champion dodgers
here's cody bellinger you can finally
show him how much you love him
mookie betts one of the all-time greats
and now a world champion
clayton
kershaw the first ring for justin turner
[Applause]
congratulations one more time to the
2020 world champions the los angeles
dodgers
is one of the earliest meetings by
calendar date major league history that
the winners of each of the last two
world series have got together here in
the first weekend of the season with 26
year old 2019 all-star right-hander
walker bueller yeah it's a
growing list of how much better year to
year this guy gets i mean the resume
builder that he has already has
is going to be fun to watch as he
continues to climb the ladder and a lot
of records but
he's a fastball get after it bulldog
tight pitcher and he will
elevate the fastball
especially today
seven and a half strikeouts courtesy of
fed mgm we'll keep our eyes on that foul
pop
max muncie with that high sky there to
make the catch and there was the high
fastball in the upper part of the zone
that really has given broglie some
trouble trey turner off to a good start
homering in back-to-back games to start
the season
there's the next 3-2 pitch and another
fast ball shot to the right side of the
infield
3-3-2 pitches all of them fastballs
right on brand for walker bueller
he rarely swings early and he will take
his pitches because he's a master of the
strike zone
here is juan soto
got him on the high gas
a one two three start to the afternoon
for walker bueller showing off the
lively fastball joe ross on the mound
for the visiting nationals and john the
last time we saw him as we talked about
a moment ago
it was game five of the 2019 world
series yeah you take all that time off
and you
take on the defending champs welcome to
your first start
good slider to strike out chris taylor
here's corey seeger
caught looking this time
however two strikeouts start the
afternoon for joe ross
that's how you do it after a year and a
half
joe ross meanwhile unconcerned with fan
capacities or who uses what concession
stand of course he is off to a very good
start today
limiting the big swinging dodgers to
just a single their first time through
the order think about the last time we
saw him out there we kind of glanced
over this look it was game five of the
world series but he was not supposed to
start that night that's when max
scherzer woke up and couldn't move his
neck
and ross went out there and pitched
admirably over five innings as he is
this afternoon
he played three shutout innings in los
angeles so far a scoreless ball game top
of the fourth and trey turner leads
things off for the nationals turner soto
and zimmerman here for the gnats against
walker bueller
turner grounded out in his first try and
sends a fly ball into right here for
mckinstry running out of room may he
hangs on to make this catch
he is having a heck of a time with that
short wall in right and it angles right
obviously the more you go up and you're
just not prepared if it's taller you can
you can cushion the ball with your body
we talked about leading the league in
ops last year for soto at the age of 21
his career obs
972
over his three seasons
that one's past lux into right
that was a great example of being spread
out with two strikes
and doing what that young man does
better than any young player i've ever
seen come in the game including mike
trout the trouble with a guy like soto
is can you throw a third perfect pitch
he just makes you he does they they
don't he doesn't give you an easy strike
full count from walker bueller here's
the payoff pitch home
and there's a strike that's lined into
center field a two out single
well we called the last two out two on
opportunity for the nationals their best
opportunity to score but it set up the
number nine spot of the order this is an
even better opportunity now with starlin
castro
02.
and a curveball that's bounced to the
left side turner's got it
you know what he ended with 90 pitches
again i'm amazed at the outing that joe
ross had
what a great job for him
five scoreless innings struck out four
allowed two singles to walk two batters
in his first start since october of
2019. justin turner now he is
responsible for both of the dodgers hits
in this game two singles against joe
ross justin turner lifts off a high
drive out to left center field and that
one's gone
justin turner is a one-man band this
afternoon in l.a
all three dodger hits and the only run
of the day
courtesy of their 12-year veteran third
baseman that's amazing 0 for 16 the rest
of the lineup justin turner who got
resigned got his ring
walker bueller gone after 90 pitches and
six shutout innings in favor of
left-hander victor gonzalez so bueller
clean over six innings six singles got
out of a couple of two out jams no walks
in a very good afternoon will be a first
time meeting between former teammates
trinin and ryan zimmerman
zimmerman shoots it back up the middle
dodgers hadn't played perfectly and
despite having runners at the corners
and nobody out the nationals are turned
away in the eighth
former milwaukee teammates to
potentially decide an outcome here in
los angeles this afternoon
and the defending world series champs
improved to six and two with a
one-nothing shutout win in their 2021
home opener